so in the comments section of my
previous video on omega-level mutant
switch focused on Hope Summers a couple
of you expressed some confusion as to
where omega-level mutant stood and the
overall pantheon of Marvel's character
hierarchy as well as how the hierarchy
stands in relation to everyone from the
most powerful cosmic entities all the
way down to street level criminals and
so in order to answer this question
we're going to start from the top and
work our way down providing an
explanation on how these various levels
of power compared to one another and
ultimately how omega-level mutant fit
into all of this
some may also want to point out is that
as we get into this first video where
the characters that we'll be discussing
here their level of power exists on such
a scale that the easiest way to explain
their capabilities is to simply say that
they can basically do everything you can
imagine ranging from warping reality to
reading minds to phasing individuals out
of existence
so beginning with the top we have the
one above all within the realm of the
Marvel multiverse the one above all is
the supreme authority and the creator of
all things in existence including the
multiverse itself while he has only
appeared 17 times in the history of
Marvel Comics including an encounter
with spider-man on the whole most fans
usually attribute him to being Jack
Kirby in the Fantastic Four volume 1
issue number 511 depicted the group
traveling to heaven where they literally
enter the office of Jack Kirby in the
midst of drawing another story within
the realm of Marvel Comics having said
that the power possessed by the one
above all is believed to be unquestioned
and unchallenged and that he can
literally do everything
however the beyonders house a strange
relationship to it what I mean here is
that during Jonathan Hickman to run on
Avengers and New Avengers during the
time runs out storyline leading up to
the start of Secret Wars the beyonders
had essentially laid waste to the
multiverse and eliminated all of the
cosmic entities now why the one above
all never made an appearance in this
story is unknown and because almost
nothing was known about the beyonders
until time runs out information on how
they compare to the one above all is
limited at best however what Hickman did
establish is that the beyonders hails
from outside the Marvel multiverse and
presumably control of the one above all
now all this is not an absolute answer
we can infer that the power of the
beyonders likely rivaled that of the one
above all and then considering the fact
that the one above all has not appeared
in the new Marvel prime universe it
would stand to reason that it was
destroyed during the collapse of the
multiverse following the one above all
comes the fulcrum now again this
requires us to delve into a bit of
conjecture and haphazard guessing since
the fulcrum has only appeared four times
in Marvel Comics however because these
appearances were within the pages of
Neil Gaiman's II turtles which serve to
explore the Marvel cosmos Diamond
established that the fulcrum had
functioned as a de facto leader of the
Celestials the Watchers and various
other races now the story also hinted at
the idea that the fulcrum was an aspect
of the one above all but whether this is
true or simply an interpretation is
unknown all we really know is that his
power seems to rival that of the one
above all from here we jump to Protege
now this is a character that we've never
talked about
or and largely because we didn't really
have a reason to but protege was an
artificial being hailing from the earth
691 continuity and had the ability to
duplicate the powers of any being after
watching those powers used now the
reason why this puts proteges in such a
high ranking is that within his own
reality
anyone who attempted to oppose him was
almost immediately eliminated since he
was able to copy their powers and this
pattern eventually led to the Living
Tribunal in the cosmic entities of Earth
691 s reality doing battle with Protege
with a living tribunal quite literally
absorbed protege in order to bring his
rampage to an end now picking up with
the Beyonder and molecule man the reason
why we're tying these two together is
that the history of the Beyonder and
molecule man actually went hand in hand
in addition to this with both the
Beyonder and molecule man they exist in
two forms pre red conned and post retcon
when it comes to the level of power most
associated with the Beyonder and
molecule man characters the extreme
abilities they displayed are all pre red
calm which is to say prior to molecule
man's power reduction in Fantastic Four
issue number 319 and prior to the
beyonders origin red Conn and New
Avengers Illuminati number three which
established with the Beyonder was an
inhuman mutant hybrid in the
publications before these records
including secret Wars one from 1984 and
secret Wars two from 1985 the Beyonder
and Owen Reese were two sides of the
same coin and that when Owen Reese was
performing his experiment a malfunction
had allowed him to tap into a pocket of
energy from another dimension and after
absorbing one-half of its power the
other half had become sentient and
formed itself in the shape of the
Beyonder now a distinction that I do
want to make here is the difference
between the Beyonder and the beyonders
while the energy accessed by Owen Reese
during his experiment was placed there
by the beyonders themselves the Beyonder
is not a member of the race instead he's
pure energy which took on sentient form
and simply referred to itself as from
beyond since it initially had no
knowledge of the universe or what it
meant to be alive but the result was
that regarding their abilities
the pre-write Kombi under a molecule man
were the most powerful beings in
existence - the one above all the folk
home and protege and that both molecule
man and the Beyonder could control the
very fabric of the multiverse itself
this was established in secret Wars -
when the Beyonder sought to bring an end
to reality and battle Owen Reese and
conflict that spanned multiple realities
and almost ended the multiverse itself
now if you're interested in learning
more about these characters I have
videos you can check out in the
description but from here we jump to
some of the different versions of the
Celestials with the most notable being
scathing the approver now in my video
about the Celestials which you'll also
find in the description while their
origins and history have been retold
several times over the course of novels
publications on the whole the Celestials
are considered to have been the creators
of mutants and appear on earth every few
thousand years - judges inhabitants and
destroy them if deemed unworthy now if
you're interested in learning more about
this judgmental process or the
Celestials themselves you can see my
video in the description but while the
celestial order did have its hierarchy
of most powerful - least powerful
occasionally a member of their order
will experience emotion or in some
capacity become elevated from the rest
of the Celestials to achieve a new level
of power far beyond their counterparts
hailing from the same reality is protege
scathingly approver doesn't actually
engage in battle and instead simply
approves or disapproves of situations
however because as role requires send to
cope with any situation that might arise
skatin is largely considered to be
nearly as powerful or equal in power to
the Living Tribunal however within the
realm of what Comics skatin the approver
functioned as a plot device so that
during the battle with Protege scape and
simply held protege captives due to the
fact that protege was unable to copy the
abilities of skatin for reasons that one
explained but the result was the
following his imprisonment The Living
Tribunal absorbed Protege due to be the
only option available in terms of
keeping protege away from the rest of
the Marvel multiverse
now following skating the approver we
get into the territory of the Living
Tribunal now where everyone that we've
mentioned so far with the exception of
the one above all the Beyonder and
molecule man are confined to a single
reality the Living Tribunal is
multiversal meaning that it's a singular
being that can enter and exit any
reality it desires serving as the right
hand of the one above all and that the
Living Tribunal exists to monitor all
major events in every reality and ensure
that no one bean becomes too powerful
and upsets the cosmic balance the
clearest cut explanation of the Living
Tribunal role came during the events of
Infinity Gauntlet and Infinity Ward in
the Infinity Gauntlet event Thanos had
assembled the gauntlet for the purpose
of usurping the role of eternity as the
representation of the universe itself
and because of this
letting Tribunal had decreed that if
eternity was unable to maintain his
position as a universe in physical form
then Thanos taking his place was simply
the natural order of things however
following the conclusion of the Infinity
Gauntlet event and going into infinity
war when Adam warlock had seized control
of the gauntlet he did not seek to take
the place of eternity and instead look
to be absolute ruler of the universe
alongside eternity because of this
bloody tribunal decreed that Adam
warlocks goals would upset the cosmic
balance of the universe since there
cannot be two representations of the
same universe and in turn ordered him to
disperse the gauntlet prohibiting it
from ever being assembled again from
here we transition to Omega level
mutants and focus on mad Jim Jasper's
and Frank Lloyd Richards now if you're
interested in learning more there are
videos in the description but regarding
these two debates rage on who the most
powerful of these beings are and while
they are both astronomical in terms of
their abilities they each have their own
weaknesses which are little crippling
regarding Jim Jasper's his ability to
work reality was not only Universal but
multiversal in the sense that the
Jaspers warp threatened to destroy the
entire Marvel multiverse had Jasper's
original universe not been destroyed
however when it was revealed that there
was a more powerful man Jim Jasper's in
the main Marvel timeline his crippling
weakness came in the fact that while his
reality-warping powers were vast he
physically needed a reality to warp this
was demonstrated in the fact that he was
destroyed after being taken to an empty
universe with no reality whatsoever
where he was reduced to a normal human
and destroyed for Franklin Richards on
the other hand his powers are not quite
so limited while he has capable of the
same feats as Jim Jasper's Franklin can
create something out of nothing
this was demonstrated in Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four and future
foundation stories when Franklin had
created a wholly new universe and the
palm of his hands without reducing the
mass of his existing universe the issue
here was that Franklin as a child was
still learning to use his abilities and
were Hickman's run did show us what
Franklin was capable of in the future
and the years leading up to secret Wars
his full potential had yet to be reached
however when the day came in his full
power was achieved which was seized
during the ending of Secret Wars
Franklin was essentially the new one
above all and that he was literally
creating a multiverse
for the all-new all-different marvel
timeline
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know what you guys think about going
through and ranking these various
entities and beings within the Marvel
Universe and I will catch you guys later
peace
you